what's up squidows and welcome back to
the fifth lesson
of economics my name is joey and today
we're going to be talking about the
newest weapon
in splatoon 2 the splat brella now we've
all had the chance to play around with
it for the last two weeks or so
and it's an interesting weapon for a
variety of different reasons
the most obvious one being its unique
secondary fire we'll get to those
specifics a little bit later in the
video
but for now if you're still not sure
which weapon to really use
you can check out the other economics
videos in which i talk about salmon run
other weapons to use you know a
breakdown of which one is
best for you uh even gear if you'd like
so far all the economics lessons have
been about an
all-encompassing aspect of the game but
this lesson will be
all about the splat brella because i
feel it introduces enough new abilities
and
techniques to kind of warn its own video
but anyway let's talk about how it feels
to use
[Music]
now umbrellas are the first brand new
weapon type
in splatoon 2 which means they have
their own victory pose they
are completely different from all the
other weapons in the game but that
doesn't mean they
don't share some similar qualities with
other weapons
for example the gun itself fires a short
to mid-range shotgun blast
and it's not a rapid-fire weapon meaning
that it's kind of similar to a slosher
in that you'll need to pull the trigger
for every single shot
also similar to a slosher is that it
kills in two direct hits
so if you're at point blank range two
trigger pulls
they'll be splatted and also also
similar to a slosher is the brella's ink
spread
now it'll lay down a patch of ink with a
good size radius and
along with it a wide trail behind it now
this makes
umbrellas really good for inking you can
cover some ground really quickly
and for comparison this is what the ink
spread looks like
compared with the standard blaster on
the left and the standard slosher
on the right so you can kind of see it's
it's very similar and very good for
inking
but let's get into the real reason
behind using the brella which is the
shield here
pressing and holding the trigger will
open up the umbrella and
that shield that opens up will guard you
from incoming ink
now this is a good way to protect
against head-on attackers
it can block a majority of special
attacks and most weapons
it doesn't protect against everything
like if you have someone going
head-on at you unloading a bunch of ink
it will break down and they will be able
to splat you
but it can withstand quite a bit of
punishment now i'll probably have to do
a little bit more testing after this but
right now it looks like it can withstand
a lot
uh but one thing to keep in mind when
using the brella is that you walk
really slow when you open it similar to
aiming with a charger or revving up a
splatling
you won't be able to move that much but
you want to be able to
use that shield to your advantage once
an enemy inkling sees it and they know
they can't bust
through it they may try to you know swim
around you and that's when you drop the
brella
drop the shield and splat them when
they're in the ink but of course that's
not all that the brellas can do if you
continue holding the trigger eventually
you'll launch the shield portion which
travels in the straight line
on the ground and it leaves behind a
trail of ink that you can safely swim
behind
now the speed is not quite as fast as
say
a curling bomb and i wouldn't say it's
the most
ideal way to travel like there is that
delay before the shield actually
launches
that kind of negates the speed increase
that you get from swimming behind it
so i wouldn't say it's the fastest way
to go but if you're traveling across
un-ink territory it's not a terrible
idea one tactic
i actually like doing is launching the
brella towards an enemy and then you
hide in the ink
and see if they attack the brella
because most of the time when you see it
coming towards you
you you assume that the the person
launching it is going to be swimming
right behind it
so they might chase after the umbrella
in which case you can pop up
splat them and then be on your merry way
and so for this last portion i kind of
want to talk about
my thoughts and kind of opinions on the
brella
and i'll be honest the first couple
games that i actually played with this i
ended up
getting zero splats it was mostly
because i was experimenting and
kind of seeing what the weapon could do
but i feel like brellas will typically
not get the most splats in the game like
i don't think that they're the most
offensive weapons and they do have a
wide spread but their fire rate is
kind of slow it's not like a tri-slosher
where you can you know get them in two
hits
right away you know if i'm chasing
someone and i don't hit them
at point-blank range it's going to take
me way more shots than just two in order
to splat them
i also don't think that they have quite
the range to compete with
you know other sloshers or even other
weapons you know like a splattershot pro
is going to outrange it
you know a blaster is probably a closer
comparison to the brella
uh with the delay in between the shots
and the emphasis on
accuracy over you know rushing someone
down
but i feel like the shield is where
you'll succeed the most
your approach is going to be very
similar to a splatling like you're going
to be
backing up the shooters in the front
people taking point
will probably rely on you to cover them
you can also like survey the landscape
and then spot a location that you want
to move to
or if you see an enemy inkling in a duel
with one of your teammates you can
launch the brella towards them
and then swim behind it and try to
surprise them there like overall if you
use a brella you'll probably be in a
more supporting role than like in the
front lines
you know it is a satisfying weapon to
get splats with but the best way to use
it i think is
probably flanking and you know coming at
people from the sides behind them
so you can get a direct hit and splat
them really easily
now as for recommendations for abilities
on your gear i will say
ink saver for sure now when just
shooting it normally
it doesn't drain too much ink but it's
when you open up the umbrella
hold it out and launch the shield that's
going to drain a third of your tank
and if you're caught trying to use the
shield without enough ink you'll end up
putting it away and being
a sitting duck for your enemies to splat
you now the standard splat brella comes
with
a sprinkler sub weapon which makes it a
good support for your team
and it has probably the most fitting
special weapon with the ink storm
there's nothing really too complex with
this loadout both of these
uh abilities are best used for
reclaiming and maintaining territory
uh you want to use ink storm usually
right away once you get it
there's no reason to hold on to the ink
storm you just want to throw it out as
soon as you get it
and as for the sprinkler just make sure
you use it generously you want to throw
it on top of
high ledges on top of walls to make sure
it rains down as much ink
as possible alright so that should cover
just about all you need to know to get
started with the umbrella uh for now at
least
people i'm sure will be coming up with
strategies as i get more familiar with
the weapon
so i hope you guys enjoyed this latest
economics lesson
uh i want to thank you guys all for the
comments questions
and discussions about the game you know
it's hard for me to know everything
and you guys have been super helpful in
the comments patching the holes in my
knowledge
now i know nintendo's about to drop a
couple of huge updates including new
stages for turf war
salmon run and the bubble blower special
and i'll be back in a couple of weeks to
talk about those
but in the meantime if you have any
suggestions for the next lesson
anything that you're dying to learn
about the game you can write in the
comments below or ask me on twitter at
uncle fuzz
so again thanks for watching and i'll
see you squids next time